Here we are in
LibreOffice, and you'll
see that we have all
the data we discussed
in the previous videos loaded
into the spreadsheet here.
Let's take a minute to
familiarize ourselves
with how the data is set up.
So here we see we've got
the number of surgical teams
per department
per day, and we've
got it listed by department--
all five of them are here--
and by day of the week-- Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday,
and Friday.
Remember, for all
departments, we
have the same number
of teams in per day,
except for oral surgery,
because the oral surgeon is
only present on
Tuesdays and Thursdays.
Scrolling across, we see that
for all five departments,
again, we've got the minimum
number of operating rooms
that each one requires each day.
This is simply 0.
As we keep going, we
see the maximum number
of operating rooms that each
department requires each day.
Going down to the
next set of data,
we've got the weekly
department requirements.
We've got the minimum
and maximum number
of operating rooms that each
department requires each week.
We also have the weekly targets.
This is data, because it
is set by the departments
before the operating
room manager has a chance
to schedule the operating rooms.
So this is our problem
data, and now let's
go down to our
decision variables.
All right, so here are
our decision variables.
You see that we've set
up a decision variable
for each department, and
for each day of the week.
Right now, they're
simply set to 0,
but we've colored them yellow,
so they'll be easy to see.
Let's now set up a
column for weekly totals.
Let's put that here.
All right.
So let's fill this in.
The weekly total
for ophthalmology
should just be the sum of all
of the number of operating
rooms assigned to ophthalmology
from Monday through Friday,
so that's this entire row.
Just like that.
And we can drag this formula
down for every department.
OK.
So now, if you actually go
through each one of these,
you can see up in
the Formula tab
that we've got the formula
for the weekly totals here.
So let's get started by
putting in our objectives
and our constraints.
So down here, I've set up
a box for the objective,
but I haven't yet put
in a formula for it.
So let's remind ourselves
what the objective is here.
The objective is to maximize
the percent of target allocation
hours that each department
is actually allocated.
So how can we calculate that?
Our decision variables up
here represent the number
of operating room hours
that each department
is assigned on each day.
We calculated the
total over here,
as the number of operating
rooms that a department
is assigned over the
course of the week.
To turn that into hours, we
need to multiply it by 8,
because operating rooms are
staffed for eight hours.
So let's create a column
that turns this into hours.
We'll put it over here, and
we'll call it weekly hours.
OK?
And this will just be equal
to 8 times the weekly totals.
Great.
And we'll do this
for all departments.
Here, this time I'll
actually write it out.
OK.
Great.
So now we've got the
weekly hours here,
but to calculate what
fraction of the weekly target,
we've got to divide it by
the total weekly target.
And the total weekly
target, we see, is up here.
So let's set this up for
every department in a column
called "Percent of Target".
OK, so this will just be equal
to the weekly number of hours,
divided by the weekly target.
OK, so we'll just set that
up for each department.
Certainly there are
faster ways of doing this,
but I don't want to speed
ahead if you guys aren't yet
LibreOffice wizards.
OK.
All right, so we've
got the percent
of target reached
for every department.
So our objective-- we
can go back to it now--
it'll just be the sum of all
of these percent of targets.
So let's add that
in-- equals sum,
and then we'll add in all
of these percent of targets.
Great.
So right now, of course, we
haven't solved the problem yet,
so we've just got
0 in our objective.
But before we go
ahead and solve it,
we need to add in
our constraints.
So down here in
green, we have a list
of all the constraints
we outlined
in the previous videos.
Let's review them quickly.
So the first one is
just that the number
of operating rooms assigned
each day is integer.
We can't assign
ophthalmology 3/4
of an operating
room on Thursday,
or general surgery 6.5
operating rooms on Monday.
We need to make sure that
these take integer values.
The next constraint is
just that the total number
of operating rooms each day has
to be less than or equal to 10.
So while we're
here, let's just add
in a line underneath
our decision variables,
which calculates the
total number of operating
rooms each day.
Over here we'll
call it total number
of operating rooms each
day, and this will just take
the sum over all the operating
rooms we assign on Monday.
Just like that.
Great.
And let's drag
this formula across
to use it for the entire week.
OK, so now we've
got that set up,
so we'll be able to do
the second constraint.
The third set of constraints
is the upper bound--
that is, the upper bound on
the number of surgical teams
that are available each day.
We also have an upper bound on
the daily department operating
room requirement, and a lower
bound on the daily department
operating room requirement.
Similarly, we have an upper
bound and a lower bound
on the weekly department
operating room requirements.
Our last set of
constraints has to do
with departmental targets.
We want to make sure we don't
give any department more
operating room hours
than they actually want.
So that means we
want to make sure
that the number of hours
given to each department
is less than or equal
to the targeted number
that they asked for.
All right, so let's go ahead
and add these constraints
into the Solver.
So we'll start by
putting our cursor
on the objective function, and
going up to the Tools menu.
And here we select Solver.
OK.
So because we started our cursor
on the objective function cell,
it comes up properly with the
"Target cell" already labeled.
We do want a maximum, so
we keep that the way it is.
And then here, where it
says "By changing cells",
we put in our
decision variables.
So we just select
them all, like this.
All right.
Now, before we start
putting in our constraints,
I want to remind you
to go into Options,
and you'll need to change
this from DEPS Evolutionary
Algorithm to LibreOffice
Linear Solver.
OK.
So you notice that
the settings--
you can choose to assume
variables are integer,
and assume variables
are non-negative.
We'll do that here.
In fact, this takes care of
our first constraint, which
was to assume that the
variables are integer.
OK.
So we've got this set up.
Now let's put in the
rest of our constraints.
OK.
So we've already taken care
of this first constraint,
that the daily number of
operating rooms assigned
is integer, and we've taken
care of that with our options.
So we'll go down
to the next one--
the total number of
operating rooms each day.
Remember that we can't
assign more than 10,
so we'll select this
whole row, which
has the total number of
operating rooms assigned
each day, and we'll say that
each element in this row
has to be less than
or equal to 10.
Great.
So on to the upper bound
of surgical teams per day.
Let's select our decision
variables, all of them at once.
OK.
And then we'll need to
scroll up to our data.
OK.
You'll notice here how I'm
inputting all these constraints
all at once.
We're actually putting in 25
different constraints, one
for each day of the week, and
one for each surgical team.
And we're just putting
them in with a single line,
by saying that all our decision
variables need to be less than
or equal to this
box of constraints.
Just like that.
OK.
So our next set
of constraints is
on the upper bound and lower
bound of the daily department
OR requirements.
So we'll put in our
decision variables again.
Scroll down to those.
And let's say that
these are less than
or equal to--
sometimes we've got
to move the solver around--
the maximum number of ORs
per day per department.
OK.
And we'll do that again
for the lower-bound.
This time we need to change
the operator to greater than.
Greater than the minimum
number of operating rooms
per department per day.
You see here that we've got
0's in for the minimum number
of operating rooms per day,
but you could conceivably
expect that one
department might actually
want a minimum number of
operating rooms per day.
For example, general
surgery, which
we see here has a weekly
target of 189 hours,
might actually want to have more
than 0 operating rooms per day.
They might want to guarantee
they've got at least one.
We'll experiment with
changing some of these numbers
after we solve the
initial problem.
For now, let's get our
remaining constraints in.
The next ones we have
are the weekly department
OR requirements--
the upper-bound
and the lower-bound.
So let's just scroll
down here in the solver
to give ourselves
a few more rows.
OK.
So here we'll put in
our weekly totals.
Good thing we've
already got this set up.
OK, so weekly totals--
this will have
to be less than the maximum
required by any department
in a given week.
So in the Value column,
we go over here,
and we put in the maximum
required each week.
We'll do the same
for the lower-bound,
again, changing the operator
to a greater-than or equal-to
sign.
OK.
And we're on to our very last
set of constraints, which
is the departmental
targets down here.
So remember, we can't assign a
department more hours than they
actually wanted to have,
because operating-room time is
so expensive.
So we'll select there
the weekly number
of hours, which we already have
a column set up to calculate.
So we'll put this in here that
the weekly number of hours
must be less than or equal to
the target allocation hours.
So scroll back up here to
OK, great.
Now we've got all
our constraints in,
and we're ready to go.
So let's hit Solve.
It may take a few
seconds-- up to 100.
In the next video, we'll look
at the results that we get,
and interpret them.
We'll also see how they change,
if we experiment with changing
some of the numbers
in the problem.